The comics have a lot of pumpkin house.
You know,
I did,
but I didn't start this fucking broad breaks out.
I'm watching it.
Two tables,
girls and guys,
and there's a girl in the middle of their fists up like she took three fucking
Tibo cloud title classes.
She's,
and she takes a swing and hits one of the bounces.
I watch this other bound to come across the room and drop her like a fucking use
rubber.
I mean,
hit her like she was a guy.
Really?
Oh my God.
I don't know how this guy didn't do jail,
but these broads,
this is what this feminist movement has taken them.
Now they jump in every time you see a fight and a football game,
the stands is women involvement.
Yet they really fucking think,
I'm sorry,
but legislation.
You can't fucking legislate the DNA out of us.
And uh,
they're always in the middle of it.
You notice that a lot of fucking broads think they can Duke it out now we'll do
our bunch.
Right.
Have a dilute.
Yeah.
They seem to,
any wonder woman movies.
Exactly.
They've been brainwashed.
Well,
there's a lot of people in general,
they think they could go around punching people like come about all these a
Antifa dorks that or a least show you face.
Well then not only that,
they're starting fights with people and they have zero idea how to find date.
They're swinging at people that you see the one guy,
a guy swings at this guy with a bat or with a baton.
The guy catches the baton [inaudible] him in the face and chaos and his head
snaps back and his head bounces off the concrete.
When he falls down,
it's awful to watch.
Like what the fuck made you think you could just hit a man with a stick?
Cause you guys disagree with each other.
Yeah.
And and you're right,
when they interview him after,
a lot of times they,
not even after a fight,
but they end to be somebody on TV.
They sound like almost swishy.
Yeah,
some of them swishing like homosexual.
So are you saying that fuck of feminine?
Well there they want to become a look.
Look,
the Antifa is just like any other group of people.
They they,
they give you a community,
whether it's a gang or whether it's a w w a criminal organization or what,
you know,
whatever it is,
people fall in line with the sensibilities of that organization.
And then you do what you can to support that organization to show that you're a
valued member.
And then,
you know,
you start wearing their fucking ski masks and hitting people with sticks and
everybody's practicing karate in the park because they think they're going to be
able to defend themselves.
The whole thing is ridiculous,
but because their life has no value outside of that.
Oh,
isn't it weird to you that,
look,
my parents were hippies and when I grew up,
I always thought that people on the left,
we're peace loving though.
That was what the,
the,
the knock was there were peace,
loving,
well educated.
But you're seeing now people on the left,
like these certain factions of them,
not all of them,
but are people that are calling for violence.
They have violent pacifists.
Ironically.
Yes.
Well,
they don't want to do it themselves,
but they're calling for other people to do,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
They're calling for people to get punished.
Like that kid with the a hat,
like raise the Osl on Ron.
Have you ever seen him more punchable face?
What the fuck are you saying?
Yeah.
You know,
it's like this extreme lack of empathy for young people to like young people
that,
that don't fall in line with their ideas.
They don't give a fuck that fuck that kid punched him,
throw him in jail,
lock them up.
It's just like,
it's,
there's a lack of empathy and a lack of thought behind it.
It's very consultative.
Media is only throwing gas on that.
Yeah.